la victime reste encore un goût on se
rencontre à radio-canada où vous avez
tourné une teneur en partie quand
symbolique on se retrouve ici pour vous
parce que c'est un moment tournant dans
votre carrière
ça a été mon premier rôle récurrent je
me souviens est même encore là j'ai fait
le bye bye tout récemment avec nos
équipements et technologies et il me
rendre ici l'entrée principale descend
les escaliers de son en bas j'ai
toujours un petit quelque chose dans le
ventre
ouais ouais ouais il tenait ça a été
comme je voyais des acteurs et les
actrices je sais je sais pas compétent
je vois ici mais j'espère au moins
quatre épisodes se pose comment ça
s'était passé un technicien vous brillez
un peu partout au théâtre à la
télévision au cinéma mais vous êtes en
quelque sorte
autodidacte même si vous avez fait vos
études à l'école nationale théâtre we
liés nous ce sens autodidacte là où ce
désir d'apprendre par soi même comme je
pense que tout part de ma jeunesse comme
on choisit comme je sais que primaire 4e
année du primaire j'allais voir au tnm
roméo juliette l'extravagance j'allais
voir chantreau avec mes parents quand
même épouse 3 0 donc ça reste pour moins
de formation avec des yeux d'enfants qui
voit des autres performer j'ai jamais
vraiment voulu deux comédiennes ça a
pris du temps sur le tard à voulons le
faire mais autodidacte ben oui dans un
sens j'ai fait l'école j'ai un diplôme
j'avais partie une compagnie théâtre
sans s'en faire des cols je jouais sas
en écosse je me mendes était d'engager
des jeunes finissants avec des gens
d'expérience justement pour fermer un
show pour qu'il ya un échange entre
artistes que les saignées la chanson
connaissait bien le métier
quel est le plus grand qu'on sait qu'on
vous a donnée justement pour l'exercice
métier là c'est pas les coques que j'ai
eu un beau
une belle france qui résume beaucoup de
chance et le guérin sur une télé et il
m'avait dit je sais pas si ça vient de
lui ou si c'est quelqu'un dont qu'il lui
avait dit ceci plus important c'est un
échange puis avait dit qu'on monte des
escaliers ya toujours des gens autour
et quand non plus haut mais peut-être
qu'un maillon bord dessins etc les mêmes
personnes que tu va croiser donc
toujours être bien et sincère avec ces
gens depuis les dix dernières années
votre carrière a eu une ascension c'est
noir fulgurante un certain moment donné
vous aviez cinq six émissions en même
temps 35 à 60 pages de texte à apprendre
comment on arrive à faire tout ça alors
on peut on peut c'est joli fait je les
fais j'étais préparé
forte heureusement que tous mes projets
des différents donc je m'amuse et je
savais que le monde de victor a requis
mardi je dois apprendre les ruptures
parce que c'est plus cérébral mon
personnage parfait alors on a des
preuves ici madame je t'ai intercepté
des textures de son mari avec jacques
faty qui me jean faire ça comme ça après
108 enfin la commission a fallu
magnifique
vous voyez c'est un appartement très
lumineux j'essayais comme de m'amuser
dans tous les textes à apprendre parce
que j'avais plein de choses différentes
à jouer est ce que je leur rêve
après je sais pas avez-vous un rituel
pour apprendre les textes
oui je les lis ces mesures mais à la
base je les lis je les lis je les lis je
ne la prend pas et je néglige les lige
le lit et après je l'écris à la main à
la main
ouais j'écris à la main au cours de deux
mille voitures on va vous revoir dans
les boues malaise
oui il avait retrouvé votre enfant gagne
c'est comment de retrouver mark heyman
justement toute cette l'arrêté je devais
martin j'ai joué d'après pas trop avec
lui
[Applaudissements]
o'malley je faisais la première saison
lui comme espèce de coup de foudre les
deux ensemble le professionnel est dans
les buts
il me fait rire et je fais rire donc on
est petit est contente de retrouver
martin puis qui a écrit l'épisode pour
madame isabelle au site il m'a dit je
lui avais dit l'eau et j'ai trouvé ma
finale l'oppidum j'ai trouvé sa pelouse
or pourquoi aimez 10 pour ton personnage
c'est ça le soit que je revenais je
devais schmitt l'année 2020 était très
occupé pour vous mais semble-t-il que
vous êtes en attente de très très gros
contrat pour 2021
il faut aussi toucher le bois est
nerveuse je pense vous aimeriez ça ouais
ouais on attendait les acteurs on attend
les réponses
et quand une réponse c'est comme si on
avait gagné à la loterie
on sent choyée on sent qu'ils ont
compris notre intelligence des mots des
textes puis des fois c'est pas nous puis
l'ambassade faut toucher du bois il faut
y penser il faut y croire
jo jo beaucoup aussi et vous savez comme
moi l'intérêt de l'enfant et son souhait
ça peut être deux choses diamétralement
opposées et la seule façon d'y voir
clair
mais ça s'appelle une expertise